hello and welcome to this video playing
arrow limit again
i had to say i remember that was the
rosso limo game
going to do it again yeah
so let's see
the same thing
yeah okay i don't think this is
too dangerous actually i think i
just go back or i can also go d6
yeah okay this has to be played anyway
so
let's do it i i analyzed this it's not
like i didn't
look at this knight e7
by the way in between there was a game
before that game that i did not upload
just in case you follow the the rating
progress or even look at the games how
was the game
that i
played but i wanted to board actually
early on because i played against
somebody who i meant to block
and i obviously forgot to block this
person
um because i suspected foul play
but um yeah anyway
um
this guy was never banned so the game
happened
i lost in a pretty bad fashion i mean
yeah it was simply not suitable for
upload because it was just not a normal
game
i was constantly thinking okay do i quit
this or what am i doing now
anyway so let's play this
and one wonder what white's compensation
is one problem here is always
that he cannot move the d-pawn
and you don't have a good move available
yeah there you have no good knight move
here
okay yeah i have b5 though
b5 knight d5
and take and knight before
yeah that looks good actually bishop d5
him
must be the critical reply
now this is interesting for for many
reasons like a queen d2 where
it looks normal but then
i go d6 and if you take c5 i can take b2
and f9 d3
so they're interesting tactics
this is a similar thing
i wonder if he can still take on c5 make
it a sacrifice
anyway this looks good
it would be great if i can get in the
knight to d3
the move bishop f5 now is definitely a
possibility
yeah so i can take here and then grab
the material i
will do that for sure
i don't think it's enough his
compensation
he doesn't have a dark squared bishop to
exploit my weaknesses here
queen before i take the rook on a1 so
i'm going to win in exchange no matter
what
he also has a knight on a3 that is not
participating yet
in the game so i don't quite see
a sufficient compensation
yeah i think he tried a bit too hard to
deviate from the game
that we had earlier in this session i
think that was probably uploaded
the day before okay so
i'll take the rook
now i think this tempo is is just
tempting to to take
i also queen f6
is also an idea
yeah but i think this must be good yeah
take it
and tempo
rook c8 is another tempo
and now i can't can i quit queen takes
d5 yeah
queen d5 25 bishop takes rook takes rook
c1 back rank mate
this is the kind of move that i think um
gets rid of the last hope
that he has okay now
queen c5
maybe
yeah attack the knight and
intend to take on f3 this should seal
the deal really
95 yeah so he tries to
play knight g4 stuff
or knight d7
so i take here knight d7
it should not win anyway and or it
should not work anyway
but i think this is this is a pragmatic
solution
knight d7 i can take
and knight g4 i can take d1 and queen c1
queen trade is enough
okay
maybe i'm just playing scared chess here
but
yeah it just stops counter play
completely so um i don't think this
works really
on bishop c4 the the line that he played
a3 is
is totally okay i think and gives a
quite interesting play it's probably
if black plays perfectly a draw but i
don't think this is enough
knight c6 c3 yeah
engine gives b5 but that cannot be bad
the key point is exactly this position
and
what is the compensation if you look at
this white only has some
a marginal development advantage
and he actually has no good move just
concretely what is the move now
you would like to get the knight out but
that is not really
possible in a meaningful way and you
cannot move the d-pawn due to that
pin so yeah and this is
really really good already take take
the engine just wants to play the simple
knight e7
this is actually yeah it makes a lot of
sense
basically claiming that you cannot take
of course
and the next move will be c4
let's say here and then c4 which is of
course greater with two connected
pawns here and well this is awful
yeah but probably i don't think what i
did is particularly bad
so i understand what he tried but
there's just not enough
it looks pretty fine that gets rid of
the pawn
queen c5 is certainly best and now rook
d8 is actually the best move i wasn't
sure if there's something
more materialistic let's say but it just
makes a lot of sense
to prevent this by simply now you can
take
and this one yeah you can take the
knight but queen c3 is just ending the
game
just there's just no move that he can
play
yeah he either leaves the long diagonal
which is over
or trade queen trade queens i can take
like this and i can actually
rook c3 is the engine move i can also do
this this is also very good of course
didn't see that but if you have one win
and yeah then it's enough to play it
so white should definitely play a3 here
and um
and be fine be fine okay guys thanks for
watching